yes exactly let's ask Yanik what
happened in this game Yanik Welcome to
our studio welcome to singfield cup it
was the first round of the new event for
you it's first time you playing here how
did it feel to play in the Hall of Fame
today yes hello um oh it was quite nice
I mean it was relatively easy game so um
I'm quite content with it uh because I
mean of course playing G is very
difficult you can play basically
anything and um I also kind of um I mean
of course I expected E4 and the RZ but
um still you know I didn't consider it
to be like top priority I mean to check
and was kind of uh because I'm not
really a buring player you know I I mean
I've played it like a couple of times I
mean in recent years but in general I
mean especially in the end game like you
know uh actually you know in some events
it's forbidden already to play this end
game you know they say no but no but the
end game can get quite interesting
uh I mean of course engines are showing
like zeros everywhere but um yeah in
general you know when uh humans do play
I mean can get tricky so I played this
A5 I think I I've had it only three
times actually with black and in all of
the games I play A5 and I mean the idea
is you know just to play you know
something um maybe let's explored and
and you know just just to get a game
yeah of course I mean like H5 and other
setups with King on C8 for example are I
mean fine for black yeah I mean
everything is kind of good but yeah but
here I mean I I was kind kind of
confused because um I mean I mean I I
couldn't because there are many ideas
for black uh for example I remember but
I think it was after Bishop F4 but I
couldn't quite recall is this bishop B4
idea and after Knight E4 for example
Bishop B6 I mean C3 A3 doesn't really
matter Bishop D5 yeah mhm but after Rook
D1 I um I kind of forgot what to do I
mean because after Bishop B before I
fought Knight D2 now it's uh it's
perhaps better version for white you
know because I don't have I don't I I
don't get to play this bishop B6 Bishop
D5 okay so I play A4 and here I mean I
mean I mean Al he could have played like
something else B4 but it's and H6 um
this was the moment you decided to start
the attack on the king side
or yeah no I mean I it's kind of the
waiting game by by now because I would
love to play Bishop V6 but um I didn't
really want to allow you know this uh
Knight G5 move I see okay so H6 H6 is
kind of prophylactic and but also maybe
one day you know I will play G5 or but
it's mostly against Knight G5 I guess so
B fre it's very principal you know just
uh you know harassing my Pawn on A4 B5
it's also kind of typical after this A5
A4 but it's also a bit risky for me C6
becomes yeah yeah this C5 score also is
uh you know not Rosy at all yeah but
here after G4 Bishop B4
um yeah actually my opponent
underestimated this uh this idea that
was played in the game um maybe he
thought that Bishop D2 and Knight B5 is
uh like he's just winning a pawn yeah
yeah no no he yeah he he was for sure
but um yeah perhaps um here's something
else
um like I don't know 94
97 okay I we check we checked quickly
with the engine uh I mean with Anish so
I know I guess KN D4 is top move I
didn't really you know expect
it the thing with C3 is I guess I can
play D5 that's that's it's important
after A3 also yeah so um I mean this
bishop D2 looked very reasonable because
I didn't like this
position uh although it's still playable
for black Apparently after F6 I mean I
uh I was reluctant to do that yeah I
mean it's just the game yeah and of
course White is you know playing for
free because even if he drops the P E6
which is you know hard to imagine but
still if he does kind of draw so yeah so
this 97 is very concrete uh I mean it's
very con conrete once he takes on B5
because uh yeah now I just want to play
H5 and um
yeah basically try you know as many
pawns as possible here I mean Knight H2
was the move for him but I
thought in general I know I have very
good compensation here I mean after some
AG Bishop B7 whatever but I wanted to
play B4 you know to have this Rook A5
idea and Haring the pawn on E5 and and
if she tries to protect it I don't know
with some moves like F4 yeah I mean
still uh some Rook A5 I guess maybe G5
in the proper moment you know it should
it should Fizz out I think eventually so
after I don't know Bishop F2 let's say
take St and G5 I guess I guess it's okay
for black it's okay so yeah and I mean
here it was kind of nice tactics but um
yeah it's important of course for me
that you know after I'm not losing after
Rook D7 because scary yeah this and my
king you know hides so um and I'm
winning so has no defense against Rook
H1 yes yes yes I mean yeah he has to
yeah I mean the draw is like the normal
result so yeah I'm quite pleased with
this game because I'm not quite you know
a bar player and it looks you know like
very mature buring stuff from black side
I hope so yeah so it's a good start you
had black pieces today and tomorrow who
are you playing and I think I think
Richard Robert Richard Robert okay yeah
wait yeah okay so it's good I mean that
you have white pieces after that yes so
what who do you think will be fighting
here in this tournament for like two
places like regarding the shape of I
guess everyone know like I so far it's
hard to say yeah yeah a lot of short
draws indeed um yeah but you know it's
um yeah I guess people will be very
solid you know trying to squeeze with
white and be ultra solid with black and
um but I mean we'll see what happens
there like it's difficult to predict I
mean anyone can win this event so um
yeah it's too soon to talk about that
exactly three draws so far and okay
let's go back to the studio to yes sir
Jo and Peter Anastasia thank you for
that and joy